watch dogs too has officially been
revealed and it's coming this year we've
got a new protagonist a new setting and
a few options for picking up the game
I'm Tony and this game spot news update
comes straight from the Bay Area
watchdogs 2 is set in San Francisco and
it's offering a preorder bonus based on
the city's most infamous criminal the
Zodiac killer the murderer returns to
the city and you'll get an exclusive
outfit for hunting him down that's a
pre-order bonus but you have a few
choices when it comes to picking up the
game amazon lists the deluxe edition at
70 bucks it includes the game and a pack
of digital customization items the gold
edition is listed at one hundred dollars
and it includes those items plus the
season pass you can upgrade either of
those to the collectors edition via that
you play shop to get a remote-controlled
version of the wrench jr. robot Marcus's
companion in the game no official
pricing has been announced for the
collectors edition watchdogs to comes to
ps4 xbox one and pc on november 15th you
can check out our in-depth preview on
gamespot but don't be surprised if you
hear more about the game next week at e3
and for all the latest news from ubisoft
you're definitely in the right place
you